Of all mankind's inventions, none was more
consequential than the birth of language.
Before its creation each person's
knowledge was limited to what he or she
experienced directly. Afterward someone
who learned something could share it
with anybody else. In this video, we'll
look at four things known about language
learning in general, and then listen to
the story of lucky Lucy and poor Pete to
understand the importance of language in
everyday life. Our brains foundation is
built through experiences early in life. Pat
Levitt from the center of the
Developing Child at Harvard University
studied our brain development over the
course of our life extensively. He showed
how the brain's ability to change
dramatically drops in the years of life,
while the amount of effort such change
requires increases. Another research
showed that at age five 90% of a kid's
brain has been formed. If during these
years the child is blocked from
receiving stimulating experiences, the
Language Center and other parts of the
brain are likely to remain weak for life.
We learn language socially by observing
and imitating others. Some 1,000 years
ago German emperor Friedrich II wanted
to prove the opposite and showed that we
develop language naturally, all by
ourselves.
He made his nannies raise some children.
they were allowed to feed and clean them,
but not to interact socially, or ever
speak a word. Not one child learned to
speak, but instead, they all died. For the
same reason
toddlers can't learn language via tape
or technology. They need to be motivated
through a human relationship, then they
pay attention and learn.
Our language brain growth is strongest
in year one. If we study the brains
development by the rate of new synapse
formation over the first 11 months of
life, and then the next 15 years, we can
see how much the first five years matter.
The growth in the part of the brain
responsible for language peaks between
birth and age 3. During this critical
period children can learn a new word
every 90 minutes and several languages
simultaneously. Our sensory pathways
responsible for vision and hearing peak
before, which makes sense because we need
to see and hear to imitate language. Four
month old infants for example, if raised
bilingual by a British mom and the
Chinese dad can already differentiate
between two languages just by observing
the lip movements of their caregivers.
Higher cognitive function such as
logical reasoning peaks only once we
have the words and know the symbols to
make sense of our world. Language makes
our world: Rich language skills allow us
to really listen, to speak well, to enjoy
reading and master writing, they can
create an entire world around us. As the
German philosopher Wittgenstein said: "the
limit of my language is the limit of my
world".  let's take for example the word
"daycare center". Some people think of it
as a "preschool" the Irish call it "play
school" and the Germans invented the word
"Kindergarten". Only if we know all three
words can we understand what's possible.
Now let's listen to the story about
lucky Lucy and poor Pete, two children
raised in two very different ways.
Lucy is raised by her mother. The mother
is an average native English speaker who
knows around 20,000 different words.
Pete's parents hire a nice nanny from a
foreign country. Instead of speaking in
her native language the nanny is told to
talk to Peter only in English. While her
everyday English seems okay she actually
knows only around 5,000 words. One
fourth of what Anne's mom knows. Year one
is when the language brain is developing
the strongest. iÍf Lucy is awake half of
the time her mom speaks she will hear
around 10,000 words per day and maybe
2500 being directed at her. Directed
language is what matters. Whenever her
mom connects a word with an actual
experience,
Lucy learns its meaning. Pete hears
English only when the nanny deliberately
speaks to him, around 1,000 words a day.
But not only is quantity lower but also
the quality. As the nanny is not fluent,
there is a chance that many words come
across broken. At their first birthday
both kids can say: "mama" and "papa".
What we don't see is that Lucy actually
already knows many many words even
though she can't say them. But Pete's
language universe is more limited.
When Lucy and her mom look at picture
books, her mom points out what they see: a
little monkey is also a gorilla, an ape,
a clever animal which uses tools, climbs
trees and lives with his mama and papa
in the rainforests of Africa. When Pete
looks at a picture book his learning is
limited by the language of the nanny. The same monkey is just cute and eats
bananas. To compensate he's given a
language app, but as Pete lacks
the foundation he doesn't understand a word.
To him, it's just a bunch of new sounds
strangely connected to colorful
characters. On their second birthday Lucy
knows already well over 200 words, the
amount where children start to learn
rules and apply grammar. Pete knows less.
Sometimes he gets frustrated because he
can't express himself. Lucy likes to go
with her mom into the park. Sometimes
they watch the old men play chess. She
doesn't understand the game but knows
that there are pawns, rooks,
knights, a queen and a king, a bishop and
a horse. One day she will learn the rules.
It will be easy because she sees each
figure clearly.
Her understanding of their special
skills is obvious. For a lack of language
Pete sees just a big checkered board and
some wooden figures which all look quite
the same: pawns, knights, bishops. To
understand the rules later will be hard
for Pete. All figures look so similar. How
could they do different things? At their
third birthday both can say their own
name and form sentences.
Lucy's vocabulary now holds 1500 words.
Pete's got 500 to make sense of this
world. In year 4 they enter kindergarten.
When Pete stands in front of the big
shelf he sees different wooden blocks,
the ball, some old toy, a horse and the
yellow digger. When Lucy stands in front
of the same shelf, she sees circles,
triangles, squares, a basketball, the red
pinwheel, the beige rocking horse and the
carton box of the lego technic digger.
At playtime, Lucy understands what others
are talking about and often takes the
lead by suggesting a new idea. Pete often
doesn't understand what she means.
If the group discusses something for
longer, he zones out because he has
trouble following the conversation. By
the end of the year Lucy knows 3,500
words, where Pete only knows 1000 words.
Lucy now forms more complicated
sentences in perfect grammar. In the
evening her mom reads bedtime stories
to her. Words she's missing, she learns out
of context. As a native speaker, the mom
can raise and lower her voice, making the
stories exciting. Fairy tales become
alive in her head and Lucy learns to
imagine and to think creatively. Pete
still speaks in more simple sentences
and his grammar is not perfect. When his
nanny reads to him the voice is more
monotone. It's more boring and paying
attention is more difficult. Words he's
missing, often remain missing. By the end
of the year Lucy knows 6,000 and Pete
knows 2,000 words.
To understand why the actual
difference in language abilities between
the two is even larger than it seems,
let's imagine that words are nothing but
tools that help us encode the world, form
thoughts, structure ideas and then
communicate with others. With 6,000 words
compared to 2,000 words
Lucy's toolbox is now three times the
size. Lucy has a huge head start as she
is entering elementary school.
Einstein by the way as a child seldom
spoke one interesting anecdote goes like
this: As he was a late talker and hardly
spoke at the age of seven his parents
were worried and tried many things to
get him to speak. At one point they were
afraid that he had learning disabilities.
At last, at the dinner table one night, he
broke his silence to say: "the soup is too
hot!", greatly relieved his parents asked
why he had never said a word before?
The young genius replied: "Because up until
now, everything was in order.". What are
your thoughts about language learning?
Can someone like Pete still catch up
later in life or maybe find other good
ways to express himself?
Maybe our point of view is too narrow
and Pete and Lucy actually balance each
other out with the different skills they
have? Please share your thoughts in the
comments below!
Millions of students from all around the
globe have watched our sprouts videos
for better learning, thousands of
teachers play them in their classrooms
to start projects, volunteers on YouTube
have translated them to over 25
languages. Our mission is to promote
learning by doing in classrooms around
the world. If you are a great explainer
and a passionate teacher and you want to
help us develop outstanding content
contact us, to support our channel with a
donation visit www.patreon.com/sprouts